أنت طبيب أيضًا لذا أريد أولاً أن
أسألك عما تشعر به وماذا
ستفعل وما تعرفه عما
يحدث فيما يتعلق
بالوضع الطبي والوضع الصحي
داخل غزة
الآن أنا على اتصال بك  زملائنا
لدينا عملية كبيرة هناك أه مع
المنظمات الصحية وأه يؤسفني أن
أقول أن ما تتعرض له غزة الآن
ليس سوى ثلاث جرائم حرب
ارتكبتها إسرائيل أولها
الحصار والعقاب الجماعي وهي
حرب  جريمة بموجب القانون الدولي
الثانية هي الإبادة الجماعية من خلال هذا
القصف الجوي الرهيب دون توقف للسكان
المدنيين والثالثة هي
التطهير العرقي الذي بدأ بالفعل
في الشمال ويخططون
لمواصلة ذلك نحو مصر أه بخصوص
الوضع الصحي الوضع
خطير  المستشفيات والخدمات الصحية
ليس لديهم ماء ليس لديهم
أدوية الأدوية اللازمة ليس لديهم
كهرباء هناك شح في كل
الموارد أه لدينا أطفال في
الحاضنات يمكن أن يموتوا في أي لحظة
بسبب انقطاع
الكهرباء أه ونقص الأكسجين
بالطريقة التي لدينا بها النساء 50 ألف امرأة في غزة
في الوقت الحالي حامل و5500
منهن ستنولد هذا الشهر أه
لدينا بالفعل حالات لنساء
اضطررن إلى الولادة في الشوارع لأنه
ليس لديهن منزل ليعيشن فيه بعد أن
دمرت إسرائيل 70 ألف  المنازل موجودة بالفعل في غزة
أه هناك مشكلة كبيرة جدًا مع
المرضى الذين يحتاجون إلى غسيل الكلى
وسيموت الكثير منهم بما في ذلك 130
طفلًا لأنهم لا يستطيعون الحصول
على
غسيل الكلى أه لدينا أه لدينا
احتمال خطير جدًا لانتشار الأوبئة في غزة  هناك
سببان، الأول هو
تدمير أنابيب المياه وكذلك
أنظمة SE، والثاني هو
عدم وجود أي برنامج تطعيم
خلال الأسبوعين الماضيين، هل
يمكنني يا مصطفى أن أسألك عن وضع جذري، إنه
جذري، فهل تقول الأمم المتحدة نفس الشيء؟
يتهم الجانبان بعضهما البعض بارتكاب
جرائم حرب، أريد أن أعرف رد فعلك على
أشخاص مثل يار ليد وغيرهم ممن يقولون
إنها على رأس حماس، هذه الجولة على
رأس حماس، لقد ذبحوا 1400 شخص
وأخذوا 199 شخصًا بما في ذلك الأطفال
كرهائن وهم يجلبون هذا الجحيم
إلى الأسفل  على شعبهم أيضًا ماذا،
ويبدو أن هناك
صراعًا دائمًا بين حماس والسلطة
الفلسطينية، وأعتقد أن الناس يحبون
حزبك أيضًا حول من يجب أن
يدير الشؤون الفلسطينية بشكل صحيح،
ألا تنسب إليهم أي لوم
أيضًا  انظر، ليس من غير المعتاد أن
يدعي الإسرائيليون أن الفلسطينيين
مسؤولون عن قتل الفلسطينيين
عندما يقصفونهم، وأنا
مندهش جدًا مما قاله
لأنه من المفترض أن يكون
زعيمًا للمعارضة ولكني لا أرى أي
فرق بينه وبين نتنياهو.
أعتقد أنه يؤسفني أن أقول إنه
يتنافس مع نتنياهو ويقول
الأكاذيب مثل القول إنهم يحذرون
الفلسطينيين قبل قصفهم، وهذا
لم يعد يحدث، فهم
يقصفون الناس دون علمهم
وحتى أعني ما يعطيك الحق
في تدمير 70 ألف منزل.  فوق
رؤوس الناس ويزعم أن هذا ضد
حماس، هذا هجوم وليس على حماس،
إنه هجوم ضد 2.3 مليون
شخص في غزة المحاصرين، قال
شيئًا مهمًا، لم يقله مرة أخرى
وسأعطيه وصفة
لكيفية عدم قول ذلك  للحصول على أي شيء مرة أخرى
حتى لا يُقتل أي فلسطيني على إسرائيلي، أنهوا
الاحتلال، أنهوا نظام
Apper Tide، أوقفوا هذا الاحتلال
الموجود هناك منذ 56 عامًا، لقد قمتم بـ 10
حروب بالفعل على الفلسطينيين خلال هذه
الفترة الزمنية، كم عدد الحروب الأخرى التي
تريدونها؟  هو الحل بالاحتلال بإعادة
احتلال غزة مرة أخرى. أنا متأكد من أن
الخطة الإسرائيلية لا تقتصر على
تطهير غزة عرقياً بالكامل، بل
وإعادة احتلالها، بل أيضاً ضمها إلى
إسرائيل، هذه هي الخريطة التي
أظهرها نتنياهو في الأمم المتحدة، خريطة لإسرائيل.
إسرائيل التي تتضمن ضم
الضفة الغربية وقطاع غزة
وضم القدس، هؤلاء الأشخاص
يرتكبون جرائم حرب الآن وهذا ليس
جيدًا للفلسطينيين والإسرائيليين،
واسمحوا لي أن أقول إن حماس لم تكن موجودة قبل 40 عامًا
ما منعهم من
الانتهاء  الاحتلال لماذا لم
يتحدثوا عن عودة عباس إلى غزة
الآن لماذا السيد وضع وحكومته
رفضت حتى الاجتماع مع السيد عباس لماذا
منعوا كل أنواع
المفاوضات مع الفلسطينيين لماذا
منعوا جميع عمليات السلام التي لا
يمكن لأحد أن يخفيها  الحقيقة والحقيقة
اليوم هي أن ثلاث
جرائم حرب تحدث في غزة
ويجب أن نتوقف، وأنا
مندهش للغاية ومندهش جدًا من أن
الولايات المتحدة ترسل 2000 جندي
للمشاركة ليس فقط في التواطؤ
في جرائم الحرب هذه ولكن للمشاركة
في  لقد قالت الولايات المتحدة يا
مصطفى، لم تقل الولايات المتحدة
إنها تتدخل ولكن أريد أن
أسألك شيئًا عن حماس، لقد قلت
إنها غير موجودة، كما تعلم منذ 40 عامًا
أم توماس فريدمان كما تعلم
جيدًا أم من يعلم  كتب الشرق الأوسط بشكل جيد للغاية
في اقتباس صحيفة نيويورك تايمز،
يجب على المرء ألا ينسى أبدًا أن نتنياهو
يعني أن رئيس الوزراء يبدو دائمًا أنه
يفضل التعامل مع حماس التي كانت
معادية لإسرائيل بلا هوادة أكثر من
منافستها
السلطة الفلسطينية الأكثر اعتدالًا والتي
فعل نتنياهو كل شيء.  يمكنه تشويه سمعته
على الرغم من أن السلطة الفلسطينية
عملت منذ فترة طويلة بشكل وثيق مع
أجهزة الأمن الإسرائيلية للحفاظ على الهدوء في الضفة الغربية
ونتنياهو يعرف ذلك أم هل
توافق أم كما تعلم بالطبع
قال سفير إسرائيل لدى الأمم المتحدة الشهر الماضي إن
عباس ليس شريكًا  من أجل السلام، وقد
قالوا لماذا تفضل
حكومة إسرائيلية أو رئيس وزراء إسرائيلي
التعامل مع حماس على التعامل مع
السلطة الفلسطينية
المعترف بها دوليًا لأنهم يعتقدون أن هذه
هي أسهل طريقة لتجريد
الفلسطينيين من إنسانيتهم ​​وتقويض
القضية الفلسطينية
كان حل المشكلة الفلسطينية الداخلية
بسيطًا للغاية، وهو إجراء انتخابات ديمقراطية جديدة،
لو كانت لدينا انتخابات في
عام 2021، وأظهرت جميع استطلاعات الرأي أنه لن
تحصل حماس ولا سمن على
الأغلبية، لكان لدينا
نظام تعددي ولما كان هناك حكم حزبي واحد.
لن يكون هناك نظام ديمقراطي في غزة ولا في الضفة الغربية
ولكن من الذي
منع الانتخابات إسرائيل التي كانت
ضد إجراء الانتخابات
الولايات المتحدة لماذا بحق الله تريد هذه
الدول التي تدعي أنها ديمقراطية
أن تمنعنا أو تسمح لنا بذلك؟
إجراء انتخابات ديمقراطية حرة،
لا أعتقد أنني أوافق على أن نتنياهو
لا يريد أن
يتحد الفلسطينيون بالنسبة له، فمن الأسهل أن نقول ذلك إذا
ذهبت السلطة الفلسطينية إلى الوحدة مع
حماس وأجرت انتخابات ديمقراطية، كما
يقول إن الحكومة الفلسطينية الأممية
تتعامل معها  الإرهابيون إذا
كنا منقسمين يقول لا أستطيع التحدث مع
عباس لأنه لا يمثل كل
الفلسطينيين إنها لعبة دعني أسأل
واللعبة هي تقويض
الشعب الفلسطيني لذا دعني أسألك هذا كما
تعلم جيدًا رئيسك أو رئيسك
رئيس السلطة الفلسطينية
محمود عباس لا يحظى بشعبية على الإطلاق، يبلغ من العمر
87 عامًا، ولم يتم إجراء انتخابات منذ
سنوات عديدة، ولم يقم بإعداد خليفة له، وقد تم تقويضه
بالكامل، وهو
يقوض القضية الفلسطينية
أينما كانت، لذا ما أريد أن
أعرفه  منكم،
يبدو أن حماس تحاول
التفوق عليكم جميعًا، ما رأيك في
نهاية هذا الأمر بالنسبة للفلسطينيين وما
يحدث الآن داخل
الضفة الغربية، هل هناك احتمال أن
يشتعل هذا داخل
الضفة الغربية، ونحن بالفعل  لقد قُتل 56 فلسطينيًا
في الضفة الغربية على يد
الجيش الإسرائيلي، ويحدث شيء أكثر خطورة،
الأمر لا يتعلق الآن بحماس، بل
يتعلق بالمستوطنين الإسرائيليين الإرهابيين، حيث
يتواجد المستوطنون الإسرائيليون بشكل غير قانوني في
الضفة الغربية وهم يهاجمون
الفلسطينيين حتى الآن وقد
طردوا 20 شخصًا.  المجتمعات الفلسطينية
تقوم بعملية تطهير عرقي في
الرملان في وادي الأردن وفي الخليل وهم
يهاجمون الفلسطينيين
المدنيين الفلسطينيين بالفعل كما قلت قُتل
56 فلسطينيًا في
الضفة الغربية وبالطبع الناس في
الضفة الغربية غاضبون تمامًا وهم
يتظاهرون  ضد
الغزو الإسرائيلي وعلى الرغم من أن هذه
المظاهرات سلمية وغير عنيفة إلا
أنها تتعرض لهجوم بالبنادق من قبل
الجنود الإسرائيليين الذين يقتلونهم. لقد
تنافست مع السيد عباس في عام 2005 على منصب
الرئيس، وأنت تعلم أنني كنت في المركز الثاني في
هذه الانتخابات، وأنا لا أتفق مع الكثير
من آراءه  السياسات وخاصة أنني لا
أتفق مع حقيقة أنه لم
يسمح باستمرار الانتخابات
وإجراءها ولكن في هذه اللحظة بالذات
يتعرض كل الفلسطينيين لهجوم من قبل
التطرف الإسرائيلي من قبل
نظام الفصل الإسرائيلي ومن قبل
الاحتلال الإسرائيلي وذلك  لا أستطيع الاستمرار،
مصطفى بطي، شكرًا جزيلاً لك أه على
وجودك معنا وأريد أيضًا أن
أشرح عندما يتحدث عن
التطهير العرقي، فهذا يعني أن العديد من القادة العرب
يشعرون بالقلق بشكل لا يصدق بشأن
النقل القسري للسكان وملك
الأردن يتحدث مع أكبر عدد ممكن
الناس قدر استطاعتهم يشعرون بالقلق الشديد كما
قلت للسيد أنه
سيتم إخراج الفلسطينيين من غزة وقد لا يكون
لهم الحق في العودة، وهذا ما
كنا نناقشه طوال اليوم
أيضًا في هذا البرنامج على  هذه الشبكة